day breaks in sauna Yemen as the call to
prayer rouses the inhabitants of this
ancient city as it has for hundreds of
years this capital city nestled at an
elevation of over 7,000 feet in the
yemeni highlands is one of the oldest
continually inhabited cities in the
world in the medieval areas towering mud
brick houses with white plaster
highlights are oddly reminiscent of a
spectacular gingerbread city while in
the labyrinth insuk's Yemenis haggle for
spice the jewelry and other goods just
as they have for centuries a walk
through these narrow passageways quickly
reveals one striking piece of
merchandise an accessory the Yemeni
gentleman can't be without the John via
these ornate early knives are worn
prominently tucked into thick
embroidered belts and while they may
seem fearsome to Western sensibilities
the John BIA is almost never used as a
weapon instead it serves as a sign of a
Yemeni manhood in a cramped quarters of
the soup blacksmiths intently work metal
into the unmistakable hooks shape blades
Rose of gleaming daggers are proudly
displayed in market stalls their prices
range from a few dollars to a staggering
1 million dollars for John Deere with
impeccable craftsmanship and an
illustrious history but the prestige of
these items can come at a high price
other than money the worth of these
daggers is often defined by the handle
traditionally made from rhinoceros horn
prized for the unique patina it exhibits
zombies have often been cited as a major
underlying cause for rhino poaching
despite bans by the Yemeni government an
international community on the trade of
horns they continue to be used by some
knife makers conservationists and
government officials have tried to stamp
out the use by encouraging alternative
materials like water buffalo horn or
camel hooves but in this country were
changed creep slowly and tradition
remains strong a rhino horn Jumby a--
may be a status symbol for some time to
come